I'm really excited to meet our next guest
because she is someone who's been putting all of her time
and energy into doing some real good in her community
of Charlotte, North Carolina.
She's taken her party planning business
and turned it into a love and appreciation machine
for local seniors in a campaign that she calls,
Adopt a Grandparent.
And here to tell us about it, and by the way, gosh,
it's Tiffany Marino.
Hello Tiffany.
(crowd cheers and claps)
Tiffany, aah, Adopt a Grandparent is so smart
please just tell us about the program.
I just wanted to do something that was going to
be for others.
We've been so fortunate during COVID to stay busy
with our balloon business.
And we, you know, I just decided one day
another balloon artist inspired me
in another part of the country.
And I said, "I think I can do something like this."
And I just came up with my own twist on it
and it just has taken off.
Well, I just love this
and I love what you're doing.
And I wanna know what it's like there on the ground
when you're there making those deliveries?
What kind of reactions do you get from people?
Well, first we mostly only see staff
besides through windows and things like that
and just like some outdoor if they're able to come outside
to receive the balloons but just from the staff alone,
when they come and they
Aah, look at that.
get the balloons from us they are
so thankful and so appreciative.
I get goosebumps when I think about it .
And they, the staff is just so thankful.
They said, "Oh, so-and-so inside was so excited,
and they're so surprised that somebody
wanted to do something that doesn't even know them."
And just, you can tell that they have been working so hard
to bring smiles to these senior's faces
and just knowing that they're just delivering all this joy
that we were able to provide, I mean,
that you just really can't get any better than that.
Yeah, that a joy, right.
Yeah it is.
And you set out a goal
of reaching just 50 seniors,
which seemed like a big goal at the time,
but you've now reached 900.
I know, I know.
(crowd claps and cheers)
By raising over $24,000, is that correct?
Yes, I think it was just, you know,
I wanted to do it where we weren't gonna make money on it,
we just wanted to do a nice thing.
And just, I think, that that amount of money
knowing, you know, if you're sitting at home
and you can't volunteer, people still want a chance
to give back.
They still want to do something.
And we just happened to come up with an idea
that is out of the box and you know that you're providing
joy to people who need it more than anybody else.
The loneliest people that there are right now
are the seniors.
Yeah, and they can just look at those balloons
and know like that balloon said, you are loved,
they are loved.
And those cards, I think those cards
have so much power.
Oh my gosh.
It just really can't do anything
that just warm your heart so much.
Well, thank you, Tiffany, for everything
that you are doing.
Adopt a Grandparent makes so much sense.
It's so amazing. (crowd cheers and claps)
Okay, so go to TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com
and let's drive up support for Tiffany's business,
Adopt a Grandparent.
Thank you so much, Tiffany, truly.
(upbeat music)